in dieser stadt gab es noch nie einen
schwarzen kopf wir glauben sie sind der
mann der hier neue wege ebnen könnte ist
ein meisterwerk wie man es von spike lee
oder ich zumindest von 2 gegen dieser
form eigentlich gar nicht mehr erwartet
hatte und umso größer umso schöner waren
die überraschung in cannes als wo der
film seine internationale premiere
feierte und auch den sogenannten zweiten
preis nehmen konto nicht begonnen hat
als dieser film halt gibt das ist eine
ganz unglaubliche geschichte die aber
tatsächlich wahr ist jedenfalls zu
ungefähr was kann ich für sie tun
nun da sie fragen ich hasse schwarze ich
hasse juden mexicana und ihrem italiener
und chinesen
das brillante was bei die macht ist dass
er die geschichte des schwarzen
polizisten der den ku-klux-klan
infiltriert mit der hilfe eines jüdische
kollegen braucht ja irgendwie einen
doppelgänger der weiß ist und diese
beiden erzählstränge gibt es dann noch
eine liebesgeschichte die verknüpft wie
auch unglaublich schneide zu einem
gesellschaftsbild das nicht nur eben
historisch ist und in den 70ern spielt
sondern indem er alles unter frauen
wirklich von dem event chens anfang des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
und ich möchte euch dann ich danke euch
aus tiefstem herzen dass ihr euer land
niemals an die zweite stelle
und ich denke dass der film auch
jenseits von amerika als einfach als
wirklich der brilliantes firmen machen
funktioniert auch wenn man sich für
rassismus nicht so wahnsinnig
interessiert die story ist natürlich
stehe auftritt von star wars
bist du ein weißer nicht jüdischer
bürger amerikas ja ja was ja
ich bin ein weißer nicht jüdischer
bürger amerikas wirklich teil also
obwohl dieser film so ein wirklich
deprimierende bestandsaufnahme des
rassismus in amerika ist das muss man
sagen macht er gleichzeitig eben auch
wahnsinnig spaß weil er so voll ist von
einfällen und so behielt sie mit dieser
brillanz auch widersprüche
mitnahmeeffekten inne
das ist wirklich großartig das ist beste
was bei diesen vielen vielen jahren sehr
gut klar plant einen angriff wie
schlagen sie vor diese ermittlungen zu
führen ich habe telefonisch kontakt
aufgenommen
wir brauchen einen weißen officer der
mich spielt wenn sie sich persönlich
treffen
bist du für die weiße rasse rollos her
gemeinsam werden wir ein von star wars
kriegen sie das denn hin mit dem
richtigen weißen mann kriegen wir alles
hin